for
hey everyone wow that's not where I
wanted it to go I wanted it to go the
camera there we go whoa uh hey everyone
we are streaming Mass Effect Andromeda
we are showing the first sort of after
the after the intro then this is is sort
of like the first exploration spot we
are doing this because there's kind of a
spoiler at the beginning that we don't
want to show but you should be able to
tell here and we wanted to get into like
the meat of the game really kind of skip
all that intro stuff see some of the
explorations see the Tempest which is
pretty cool this time around but anyway
I'm right into that get right to the
game oh here's the Tempest I like the
Tempest quite a bit I do too uh it looks
sleek it looks nice I like this window
view we've got right here uh a really
cool thing about the window view which
will'll show is that uh
it changes depending on where you are in
the galaxy map which is really rad uh
you kind of feel a little more immersed
in it so yeah this is like the first
time you really get on it there's a you
got a VidCon here I haven't had a chance
to use this yet in the story I think I
saw it Aaron using it really um but yeah
so we figured we're going to start out
with a tour of the Tempest and then
we're are going to land on one of the
first sort of explorable planets and you
can kind of tell us what you guys want
to see there's a certain point we cannot
show we can still
show wow loud uh we can still show quite
a bit though um this is yeah there's a
couple hours in the game and up to the
point we can show uh it took me about
six hours to get to and I play I pretty
much like talked to everyone I I did
everything I could so yeah the ship's
pretty small which uh but there's a lot
going on in it here we got the research
station which shows off uh you can do
like upgrades um you put research points
into I don't think I have that many cu I
think I just bought some stuff there uh
you can buy different upgrades uh you
can buy like Milky Way upgrades you can
buy uh it's a helius technology which is
like stuff from Andromeda and then
there's this unknown Tech which we don't
have access to
yet uh that stuff's cool so yeah they
got like a whole crafting system you can
kind of engage with uh you can buy and
sell stuff straight from the Tempest
which is really nice um you can also do
strike missions you can like access
multiplayer right from here which uh is
not well it's I guess the servers are up
Aaron said he got into one but there
there was no one playing it yeah they're
not supposed to be up till tomorrow
they're not supposed to be up till
tomorrow uh which we will be streaming
multiplayer tomorrow um but yeah if you
guys have any questions please drop them
in it looks like people are having frame
rate issues with the stream though oh
with the stream okay the game's fine uh
yeah the game is running fine the the
game runs at a pretty solid uh I'd say
30 frames to the second on PS4 which is
what we're playing it on here uh I
watched you play it on P PC it looks way
nicer on PC or I watched Aaron play on
PC yeah I think it looks way smoother on
PC they want you to look at the black
hole black hole guess there's a black
hole out the window I
didn't uh black hole yeah there it is oh
that's pretty cool damn that is really
cool man okay uh they don't like our
faces either I got rid of the PIP no
NPC's on the Tempest yes there are so we
have if I go in here I actually am going
to engage in a whole on conversation
maybe a hold off on that for a second um
we don't have all the squad members yet
though we don't you uh we have the kind
of boring human Squad members although
we will get to meet some new characters
uh in the next area we're going to go to
rer enger repeat rer toering here we can
go to engineering and talk to our
engineer Pathfinder making the rounds o
let me get a Subs up next time R we
making
out I like to be a little unprofessional
in my tone with my character spok King
actually you might want to Bow otherwise
things might start falling off the
Tempest at the most inopportune times
I'll take my chances just want to see
how things are going with the ship I can
coax more out of this baby than some
might think but we shouldn't go too far
or pushed you hard between Nexus stops
for now it just feels good to be
stretching our wings you know locked in
Idol to how do you feel about the
characters so far people same as ships
stuck on the NEX got to say kind the
fence joining the inititive
I really like some of the alien
characters you meet and I think that
seems to be the sentiment of a lot of
people from what I've talked to that is
a classic Mass Effect problem yeah I do
like Kora I think kora's kind of cool
although
there's they set something up that I
figured would sort of be an argument
between her and the main character
between writer and they just kind of
over it and I was kind of like okay okay
so here's a a thing uh I can flirt with
him you can flirt with everyone on the
ship I don't know if it pays off but I
should I flirt with them yeah let's
flirt with them yeah happy to be of
service I think you'll see the showing
up is only one of my many talents oh is
that right well I'll be sure not to
Blink wow oh
man one minute in and
already we're gonna bone on the
engineering you wanted to go I'll make
sure she can get there deal deal
all right let's get subs
up gameplay nope
audio there we go yeah
nice uh but yeah uh feel free to leave
your questions we will be checking them
and make sure to like And subscribe uh
we we're going to do lots of Mass Effect
stuff these next couple days there's
already some cool stuff on there you
should actually check out the unboxing
for um the what is it called is it just
the N7 Edition or no it's not the N7
noad The Nomad Edition Edition yeah uh
Joey did a fantastic unboxing of that we
also so we did skip the opening of the
game but if you do want to see it we do
did put up the first uh 45 minutes of
the game up yeah we skipped the yeah it
ends before that sort of big spoiler
thing that uh that we were kind of
avoiding to show but exactly but we
still show off the opening we also have
uh the Character Creator as well yeah it
it's wild I had fun with that uh it's
not as inth I'd want but it's still it's
still fun uh let's see here where do I
want to go where do you want to go go
what do we want to show we should show
them our quarters yeah let's show them
our quarters that's just nothing's there
this is also like the the vanilla Rider
too yeah I went with vanilla Rider uh
there's the medbay lexxi's in there our
Rari Doctor Who is played by Natalie
Dormer watch Game of thr a good
job yeah here's our quarters oh there's
a good view of that uh yeah black hole
dang what do you think you'll be doing
in the bed other than
sleeping go talk to the engineer guy
maybe he'll have some ideas oh so you
can customize your wardrobe here but
like I got a
hoodie um I think that's elesium orium
wants to know if we would show some
gameplay of fem Rider uh we won't for
this because that would require us to
like reload a different save Actually I
don't even think you have a save with
fem Rider I don't yeah so we're we're
stuck with uh what about theer letterman
jacket
leather Letterman can go with that maybe
yeah why not we'll go with the jacket uh
oh wait I can customize the colors uh we
will show combat um we're going to start
out in the Tempest and then we're going
to head down to the sort of first planet
you can explore where there will be be
oh you can change the colors yeah you
can change the colors uh what color
should it be what color o pink yes let's
go with the pink I think I feel like
it's
pink I don't it's not working for me I
mean I I would change the blue obviously
maybe like a
purple what if I do like a reverse like
yeah like a deep purple there and
then make that like white yeah that
actually looks not bad go for it
awesome okay so yeah we got that uh
there is a radio yep you can change you
can do your music you can actually pick
it too which I like uh and they actually
have like uh in Universe names for them
as
well the for what for the music oh so
it's like oh I didn't even know you
could go into yeah raise the volume a
little bit see if you can hear
that that's not very good no let's try
one I like this better but it's don't
think it's very good
oh here's into the
Vortex I like this all right we go this
one does this play throughout your ship
or just your quarters just your quarters
just over there that's dumb great what
if you want to have a party for your
whole crew talk to Sam our AI buddy uh
you got an email
terminal uh my
paper which is uh kind of functions the
same way it did in in two and three you
can get quests from that uh people will
just give you a lot of good fluff you
can get from it as well
lore stuff um lore stuff yes got the
kitchen is there a bathroom yep right
here waiting some of the doors take a
little long to load at least on PS4 I
was going to say what if you really had
to go but the door wouldn't load yeah oh
there's the
crew we can read all their notes perfect
yeah something about moving a
couch oh whoa I never noticed that hey
that's nice Le steg yeah there you go
PvZ
man I used to love that game on iPhone
and then they just kind of
like to the ground anyway I have a
friend who actually really likes uh
garden warfare Garden Warfare It's it I
actually seems like an neat idea I don't
know it was fun on iPhone for a little
bit but I just got over it uh somebody
says can't go out I assume they mean out
of the Tempest no we can definitely go
out let's uh someone wants to know if
the email terminal can play
crisis I like it I like
that you got a air loock which uh we can
set our load out
here so I got got my Omni blade haven't
gotten any I should buy a melee weapon
next uh you can get like an assari blade
and a kogen hammer that looks
cool uh yeah it is PS4 for those Wonder
yeah I don't have much in the way of
weapons yet on this uh this far in the
game talking to your notebook oh I was
was come on get back in
there yeah we'll we'll do we'll do a
sniper I got some armor so I got this
deep space explore armor which I think
was a pre-order bonus I didn't get that
but I didn't pre-order it but neither
did you at least not this version die uh
this is like the default
helmet um we have someone asking how the
frame rate is on PS4 it seems like
pretty solid 30 f solid 30 I haven't had
uh any issues on that front that's good
I've been playing on PC at least my pc
at home has a 970 and there's some frame
rate issues but it's not terrible uh so
here's our so far we got three Squad
members we got Liam we got uh cor and we
got Vetra I'm kind of with you like you
said I think cor and Liam are I think
cor's okay I don't really like Liam I
don't like yeah I don't uh I like Vetra
she's cool she's sort of your snarky
Garis equivalent I'd say uh so I'm kind
of going to go with these
two and oh that's the Escape pod never
know when you need
this all right uh then you got we got
our pilot here
salarian cool cool one thing I like
about this game so far there you can
also check your emails there as well is
uh they do a really good job having
Squad interactions with each other so
already there's been like some tension
between some of the squad members in in
interesting ways I like that stuff all
right let's check out this galaxy map
yeah the Galaxy map's kind of cool
although in annoys me how long it takes
between to go between planets yeah it's
a little annoying you can't skip it uh
yeah right here I'm at the black hole um
I believe the PC version does you can
get solid 60 on PC
mhm so uh so for example if I'm going to
go to this planet here it'll actually
like kind of in first person like warp
you
over
and it looks really pretty and you're
controlling this right oh yeah right
I'm totally mean too soon too
soon oh
man see I I like this although the most
of the planets themselves like you
activate like a your scanner and there's
like nothing to scan there a couple
times of an anomaly but for the most
part yeah it's not like Mass Effect 2
where you like every planet anable no
it's not like that yeah yeah I I found a
couple last night and it was just one
thing to scan in that wonder if they add
that later maybe cuz it's kind of weird
that it lets just scan every planet yeah
that is true so here we go so we're in
the helius cluster so they you don't get
the whole galaxy in this in this game
you only get the cluster um but they
it's way more indepth so there are a ton
of systems we already have access to
like four at this point in the game um
why don't we just head over to eio
let Che out I think people want to let's
get into some of the combat see how it
looks and
plays uh gam spot any female Krogan yes
the first Krogan you meet in the game is
a female Krogan yep uh if we have a
chance we'll actually show off that area
we show off the Nexus which is the
Citadel Hub equivalent in this
game yeah they they go out of their way
to just like first tur well not first
turn but you get like a female t squad
member they show female Krogan like
right away why has Sam altered frequency
detection what are we hearing Sam there
is a signal Pathfinder I recommend an
immediate examination of EOS all right
we're going to head to EOS let's do it
yeah this is pretty I like this a
lot uh someone wants to know of my N9
said is dropping below 30 FPS yes not in
the gameplay though oddly enough usually
it's in like cutscenes um this could be
worked out when the game comes out it
may just need to be better
optimized yeah um um but I mean it's not
off
like I've been able do we want to talk
about some of the the bug issues we've
been having I'm sure we'll run into some
but yeah that possible we we between how
many people are playing in the office
four or five people I think uh yeah
we've all had different unique bug
issues with this game which is a little
disheartening I feel like B has always
been really solid about uh the making
like a game that you know is going to at
least like run well be quality on the
hope we're all that
ready
C all right integrating search area from
Sam how he pulled that mystery signal
through the storms I have no idea
multisensory mutal Collision amazing
Factory fresh across the board spinning
up the compensators you're already
tuning the displays we'll get a better
read on this past than the Nexus has had
in
months what
I said a lot of people have their hopes
pinned on us they gave up on EOS can't
blame them
expect another question here yeah Andy
Burkin says I heard that each planet has
a larger Play Zone than all the Dragon
Age inquisit in all of Dragon Age
Inquisition is this true so I actually
talked to a developer a little bit about
this and all of the areas all the the
exploration areas are bigger than in
Dragon Age um Inquisition if you compare
them but you have the Mo in this you get
around a lot quick or not the mo excuse
Nomad so you get around a lot quicker I
don't know if one section is as big as
all the sections in Inquisition put
together that I can't say but these
sections are much bigger according to
the developer when I played a couple
months ago or a month ago uh somebody
wants to know if the PC version has
controller support yes it does yeah
that's actually a first
huh uh in Inquisition had that oh I mean
Mass Effect for Mass Effect
yes uh uh some people are commenting on
the on the faces yeah
so I find the the it looks good but I
find some of the faces look like the
animation seem not as good as I'd want
them to be yeah like at times I think
the animations look better in one or in
two and three than they do in this
here's my theory though and I'd have to
actually really compare them side to
side I don't think it's that the
animations are better I think it's that
the visual Fidelity is better so the
animations are more obvious
in this one is at least my the um it's
possible they're worse I I would have to
do a comparison but honestly it I don't
know it doesn't it doesn't bother me too
much personally um it bugs me it bugs
you a lot okay I think I'm I think eyes
it's the eyes the eyes look so dead ESP
the eyes are a little dead I don't know
it maybe I'm just willing to kind of put
up with that more than we're getting
lots of questions though so I'm going to
try to move on do you need to play the
other Mass effects to play this no you
do not the game uh this is very much a
Side Story and yeah so apparently
they'll reference shepher from the first
game they haven't referenced them yet
though yeah but when you pick a
character you get to choose what
Shepherd which gender of Shepherd you
had so I'm assuming they'll probably
like I wonder how the first thing I
immediately did jump on the Tempest yeah
it's cool that it's actually like in the
space run around on it would they know
they didn't have a Pathfinder um yes
this is on PS4 mhm we'll make how does
the multiplayer tie into single player I
don't know if we have gotten too much
into that we should know tomorrow though
because we're going to start they I saw
I didn't click on it but I saw an
article that went up I think like either
yesterday or early today where bow I
guess explain how the multiplayer does
feed into the single player in a small
way oo jump Jets yeah this game really
puts an emphasis
on uh kind of platforming in m ility and
it's it's it's cool it's a little janky
in spots I find like sometimes when
you're when you're trying to like get
onto things it can get a little Jank but
it's it's pretty good you think there's
something cool in this crate right there
maybe maybe we'll find out o all right
let's go uh scan this planet here uh
someone actually wants to check Aaron
Bailey says I want to get this for my
son but I would like to know if you can
turn the gore off oo good question we
could check actually yeah we might as
well check I don't think
think uh Graphics no
not uh does look like it it isn't super
gory though no it has bit super gory I
haven't seen much in the way of swears
but there's some there's some sex scenes
though apparently these are supposed to
be some of the most
uh graphic graphic that's word I was
looking for graphic sex scenes that uh
have been in a Mass Effect game so
that's probably a good thing to consider
before you buy this for your son um but
in terms of violence and Gore has been
too bad and like yeah it's been fine
when I like like I think I shot off an
alien's head but it's like it's like
green and it kind of looks
cartoony um let's see what else do we
got
here yeah uh chat uh talk away we're
here for
you okay so I'm trying to let's see I'm
protesting pre-orders but should I
pre-order this being uh being a fan of
the last two Mass effects I mean here's
my feeling on pre-orders if there's
never a I I honestly find there's less
and less a reason to pre-order as far as
like like you'll still able to get this
game pretty easily you especially if
you're buying a digital yeah so if
you're protesting pre-orders I mean I I
don't think there's any reason to I
wouldn't pre-order it yeah I wouldn't
pre-order it you know just I wouldn't
pre-order this wait for the game to come
out you know and then pick it up if you
want it yeah I mean the only time I ever
PR anything is if it's like Die Hard fan
like I know I'm going to want it and I
want the collector edition uh like with
this if you want the collector edition
maybe although it doesn't come with the
game at least whatever we opened
yesterday doesn't come with the game so
I wants to know if you can customize the
face of the default Rider yes you
totally can uh it's we have a video up
where you we show off the Character
Creator it's okay it's not as in-depth
as I would have wanted it to be
especially compared to like Dragon Age
Origins which had a really in-depth
character creator this one feels far
more limited
uh it's not it's not bad
though um all right here's one which I
can't speak to as much but I've heard
lots of issues someone wants to know how
does it play on Xbox one we're playing
on PS4 right now oh do we want to talk
about Mike's weird issue so Mike has
been playing on Xbox one I think he's
the only one playing on Xbox One and
he's had a lot of weird issues which I
haven't seen on PC sounds like you
haven't seen on PS4 well a lot of his
issues are seem to be related to the
games uh like or the when it goes into
sleep yeah when it goes into sleep mode
onbox like he'll load it up and the game
will be like frozen kind of it's really
weird I've not had that issue at all on
PS4 so I think it's something weird with
Xbox yeah I got a could be this is also
I mean I imagine there's going to be a
pretty hefty update when this game uh
somebody says how long after Mass Effect
3 so the very very opening of the game
when they leave the Galaxy is actually
like during Mass Effect 2 I want to
say uh or like between Mass Effect 2 and
three after that takes place 600 years
later so the the chance of seeing any
sort of like crazy overt references to
Mass Effect 3 are pretty slim to none uh
there there is I won't spoil it but
there is a
uh a uh reference to a character from
the previous Trilogy though uh I don't
did you see that I don't think so oh you
missed it oh you didn't explore
uh you can you can find it uh before
even this
point yeah it's fun little Easter egg I
I won't spoil it for for people is it in
the Tempest yeah uh it's in um the
Hyperion I'm
excited yeah it's just a little fun
little Easter egg should take a dip in
that water over there o what happens if
I do
that no fine nothing decent
Splash good Splash effects yeah okay
Splash
effects
uh I have a so let me show off my skills
here so we'll show off Tech skills in a
sec I actually have some points so if
people want to see a specific ability
let me know I can buy it I can buy it um
you have combat we got biotics and we
got uh
Tech uh and you can kind of buy any of
them you want for the most part a couple
of them are locked off like this one it
says you need nine skill points in Tech
before you can get the assault turret
uh however when you pick your not your I
don't know class at the beginning when
you kind of pick your like initial setup
you can pick like say the biotic charge
so you can have it at the beginning but
since I didn't I now have to like wait
until I have nine skill points before I
get the charge but you can eventually
get it if you want um one thing I'd
recommend is invest in uh combat I think
it's
combat yes invest in combat Fitness
because this allows you to carry more
than two weapons oh I didn't realize
that yes so you want to if you want to
carry multiple uh like up to four
weapons you should invest in this uh
tree right there um there's a thing
called profiles which is
where basically it's like an extra layer
that goes on top of your skills and it
has all these bonuses that are based
around the skills so like Soldier it
gives bonuses to Soldier skills so
typically if you're going to have the
soldier profile up you want to have
Soldier skills going
they also had cool extra bonuses so the
infiltrator one I have right now adds uh
when I Dash I
cloak amount time looks cool too yeah it
looks really rad there's a couple of
really neat ones there's a uh the explor
one adds a
biionic blink as your dash which is
pretty rad scan the door here yeah the
people want to see combat so let's uh oh
we're about to get into some combat
actually to unlock it orain entry to
builds uh it has this biotic charge that
lets me um like warp through objects so
I can like warp through cover which is
actually really really cool uh nav to
Max I think wants to know if we've
tested the 4K version I don't know if
the update is available yet for PS
that's a good question I have a I have a
pro uh but I have not I've been like
capturing you know for work and stuff so
I haven't actually like tested it in 4K
yet um that's a good question if it's
available cuz there is a huge day one
patch for this game
so you're a salvager got a name I'm
Ryder Clancy making an honest living by
wait Ryder as in Pathfinder the Nexus
just can't let EOS go can it however
much it fa out here Thug Life want know
if you can play as other races in single
player no no you pick between male or
female but in multiplayer actually
BioWare released a video about the
multiplayer and it looks like you can
pick from all sorts of species both from
the Milky Way from
Andromeda so
you got
that multi- ending I don't know no idea
is it released yet nope comes out next
week a week from today that's
soon all right we're going to activate
this generator which is gonna is Ryder
better than
Shephard don't know I don't know I I
like I like Ryder so far I like ryer
quite a bit Yeah Ryder's cool I don't
know if he's better than Shepherd though
I spent a lot of time with Shephard yeah
I know that's a hard that's a hard cell
let's see
um okay so oh I got to scan
okay yeah you got to hop up there right
I just did this last night I remember
this
Quest I really like the having the
jetpack it's cool it's a cool ability
option skip cut scenes uh yeah if you uh
press uh Circle uh Circle uh Square on
the PlayStation control you can like
skip dialogue and stuff like that I
don't know why you would but you
can uh how do you meet your partners I'm
guessing you mean squadmates uh we're
actually going to meet a couple soon so
yeah we're gonna meet a couple soon uh
Liam and Kora you start with and then
Vetra um you get when you get the
Tempest package
deal can't get one without the other
there's a little imprecision about this
sometimes where you're trying to get on
something real specific it doesn't for
the most part it doesn't make you do
that but it could be a little finicky I
also see people ask you about
multiplayer we haven't played
multiplayer yet because the servers
don't go live until tomorrow although uh
someone we work with says he actually
got into a game or got into a game but
didn't get a lobby but there was no one
there that's what he said uh make sure
to like And subscribe and tune back in
tomorrow because we will be streaming
multiplayer all right uh and without
further Ado we've got some combat all
right oh dang it that got that thing got
I was trying to be cool and I just I wh
whiffed it super
hard ooh I need to get yeah okay I'm
like these are like completely different
powers than what I've been using
recently so I'm like super thrown off by
this um oh she just chroner 24 is
curious if there oh that's cool yeah I
like the flamethrower a lot um he's
curious if there's different thumb stick
layouts uh H we could check so yeah
after we after we clear these we'll hop
in there and check so the combat is at
first I didn't like it that much I was
kind of not feeling it the more I play
it the more I like the combat I it kind
of grows on you like I kind of know you
like when I first started playing the
combat like when I yeah previewed it how
do you what like it feels it felt it's
it's different I seem to get used to it
quicker than you because like and that
first planet like after 20 minutes I was
like all right I really like this combat
yeah I think it took me a little bit
longer um I don't care for
so it has cover in the the sense that
when you get in it automatically uh you
automatically take cover it doesn't have
like the snap cover that the other thing
I don't like and I don't care for it but
my you kind of aren't supposed to use it
that much you're kind of meant the snap
cover is sort of there to just like if
you need to regenerate your health and
then after that you're sort of supposed
to just kind of keep moving around
yeah all right so this
guy selling a bunch of crap
uh the the flamethrower reminded people
of
igny uh so Salvage yeah let me can I buy
this remind people of igny don't buy the
Raptor is it bad I don't like it I
forgot the Raptor is the the fully
automatic sniper rifle because that's
what people
want like what that doesn't make any
sense all right I bought that uh that
Maverick I want to I haven't actually
tried it yet I love the Maverick from uh
three would longtime Mass Effect fans
like this
game yes yeah I do I do I I'm a longtime
massic fan and I like it I don't uh I I
I want to I don't want to talk too much
about
like what I yeah anyway nice I want to
wait for yeah yeah we don't want to make
uh we're not Scott's going to be
reviewing the game uh that should be up
Monday so but what I can
say at least for me
personally is that as a huge Mass Effect
fan I I love Mass Effect but I think
every Mass Effect game has always had
some
problems about it that I've had to kind
of Overlook to enjoy and love those
games and not in a bad way just like
yeah these games have problems but I
still love them despite that and this
game I'd say kind of continues that
tradition where like nope it ain't
perfect it's it's got some problems but
despite those problems I still really
really like this game so far yeah same
with me I'm having I'm having fun with
it like I'm very excited to go home and
play more of it um but yeah like you
said it does have issues like it's not
perfect but what game is yeah let's buy
some upgrades let's see here what do you
want me what do you want to see have you
have you what have you been investing in
mostly biotics okay do we want actually
exclusively
biotics there's some cool Tech stuff
uh I like they show little video which
is cool yeah that's pretty nice you can
cryo people that looks nice uh someone
to know if you can Romance the tyrian I
don't know for sure but I'm going to
guess yes uh you could definitely flirt
with her I didn't I didn't do it but you
can like I said I've been able to flirt
with everybody on the ship so
far let's
get um yeah we do read the twitch chat
uh there actually YouTube and twitch are
kind of compiled so sometimes uh the
twitch twitch chats get a little bit
buried
um but let's I forgot we're going to
check those stick layouts let's see oh
yes I'm sorry uh we can absolutely do
that okay and then let's
get this one's kind of cool it's like a
barrier
uh and I think like
later it looks like yeah you can release
it and
it'll like reinli damage which is rad um
let's get that play games Patty says are
you encouraged
to play the full game as full or to play
the game as full Paragon or Renegade to
unlock skills or achievements so there
is no Paragon or Renegade system in this
game in fact the dialogue system is very
different where it doesn't really focus
so much on you check the stick layouts
oh I'm sorry yes it doesn't Focus so
much on Paragon Renegade but it more
focuses on personality kind of
professional
unprofessional uh kind of like that I
sort of prefer it because I think it's
uh let's see configuration so add a
little bit of gray rather than black and
white yeah we can
invert uh let's see we can invert
sticks you can invert vehicle sticks or
sensitivity you can change sprinting you
can change aiming controls sustain
Powers
vibration and if I go to configuration
exploration combat Nomad uh yeah it
doesn't look like there is a southpaw
yes so there's a southpaw alt Southpaw
Gladiator Gladiator Southpaw a blasto
style which whatever that is I love it I
love the name and well so yes I'm sure
okay there you go it sounds like one of
those will probably be what you want uh
fantastic I love when games offer that
uh what was I saying though um um Arc
Joe wants to know comparing it to Dragon
Age Inquisition how's the mission in
World
layout so a huge issue I had with
Inquisition was
that most of the quests are fetch quests
there were there were a lot of fetch
quests a lot of like checklist like go
get these materials those are in this
game but they put a lot less of an
emphasis on
them and even then I've those have a lot
of dialogue in them even like just
talking to people there's been like oh
i' I've had to like actually like talk
and uh just a lot more dialogue between
your squad members I feel like my squad
members are constantly talking just
exploring around I and I really think
that helps a lot I think like just
adding more character dialogue and like
narrative reasoning for doing stuff is
is a huge help so this here is the uh
little like probes that come down um and
they'll when you find a place on the map
they will launch let me like show the
map for a sec I don't yeah that pops in
for a like I don't love the way the map
looks this is how big the map is it's
actually pretty
big uh we get to kind of explore this
part of the map which is a decent chunk
here so every time you find one of these
uh forward stations you can
automatically fast travel to it you can
also use it to change your load out
which uh let me do that yeah let's get
that madok yeah let's get the madok in
here
uh here we are load
out oh but I've I've like the mission
variety like already I've had uh a
couple cool like story missions with
like some morality and and kind of
having to make uh
choices it's been pretty good so far I I
definitely think they listen to the
complaints uh
with dragon agent inqu position where a
lot of the side missions just kind of
felt tedious and I feel like they've
been they've definitely addressed that
in a good
way all right let's do
it someone's annoyed that there's no
Paragon or
Renegade decisions so there's still
decisions and in dialogue and stuff like
that they just aren't they like it you
should it it's still very similar you're
just not like you're not going to get
points for being good or evil yeah and I
think it's more interesting because I
always found whenever Mass Effect tried
to do like a very morally gray issue
there would still be like it's like
because it was a paragon Renegade system
it's like well we have to give you
Paragon points for one and Renegade
points for another so even though there
really was no like good or bad answer it
was one was still the evil answer and
one was the good answer so by getting
rid of the the Paragon Renegade system
they kind of free themselves to have
more interesting uh choices and dilemas
all right we got a couple we got a short
question and an interesting question one
says any PS4 Pro support yes yes there
is totally PS4 Pro support this isn't
PS4 Pro though right now um and then
another interesting question is is the
genage still an issue in Andromeda yes
they address that uh they totally I have
not gotten to that point yet um but
that's a good question well you at least
have that um you can talk to a character
who and specifically ask them about the
genf AG like hey is this is still a
thing and they they totally address
which is is it a Krogan it's a Krogan
spoilers a Krogan talks about the G uh
yeah so here I'm in the Nomad what do
you want to know about this thing uh
look at me oh boy the wheels seem like
this look at the suspension I don't know
how you even just wrecked it yeah watch
it there's like yeah
oh I love it I like the Nomad I think
it's fun it feels pretty good yeah look
at that just oh yeah so here we are
exploring the planet outside of that
little uh base there is a low level of
radiation so if I get out I can be out
for a little bit amount of time but if
you see in the bottom uh left it takes
down uh the nomad's pretty cool uh you
hit L1 it activates this like four-wheel
allterrain which um you move a lot
slower but you could use it to then get
up um inclines which uh oh let's not go
in the water gray fox 3D wants to know
how the resource farming is which I know
you should pull up yeah pull up yeah
right here we got a mining uh drone so
as you're driving in The Nomad you'll
get a little ping that says hey there's
some resources here you pull it up and
then uh you just hit the button to probe
and get
resources it's pretty easy my issue with
it is
thatc uh it it's kind of difficult
to search for a specific if you want a
very specific mineral like you're trying
to build uh like a very specific gun
you're like well I need this specific
resource it's kind of there's no real
way to like you know
say like I want to search for this type
of mineral yeah um you can buy minerals
from like shop vendors which kind of
helps that out but I I don't know that
that kind of that's that's part's not
great uh here's an interesting question
would you suggest this game to people
who aren't huge Mass Effect fans so we
kind of established that if you are a
Mass Effect fan this is
definitely this this is worth your time
yeah I think this is worth your time I
think you'll be satisfied yeah I think
you'll enjoy it but what if because like
Peter for instance who hasn't played
much of Mass Effect if Mass Effect at
all he's been playing Andromeda and he
isn't too wild about it no he's not yeah
but as someone who's not interested in
Mass Effect what do you think would you
recommend this game to someone who's not
that interested in Mass Effect man
that's a good question is it it's really
going to depend
on what you like in a game you you if
this game gets you got to be into like a
lot of dialogue yeah I mean cuz like a
lot of people here in the YouTube chat
are saying this is boring this is like
we want to see combat like you're just
driving around and like that kind of is
Andromeda like it's not as action
focused as Mass Effect 2 or three yeah I
in fact I think I remember a lot of
people when they showed footage of this
game they mostly showed the combat and
it's because the rest of the game is
like it's a lot of talking there a lot
of yeah and and if that's what you like
you will like this game a lot because
there is a lot of uh dialogue in this
game yeah lots of dialogue lots of
lore it's but I'm just getting random
okay yes
um but yeah I think overall it would
very much defend on depend on the person
if you are if you like RPGs and you're
okay with a game that kind of takes its
time I would say go for it but if you
want to get right into the
action and you're not super wild about
RPGs maybe not I think the setting
though is just incredibly fascinating
like that is why I I like the setting a
lot i' I've always been a huge like
sci-fi same with me nerd so I've always
like LED Mass Effect just from a setting
perspective and I really like what
they're doing so far with
Andromeda o do it I always find myself
accidentally cutting off my characters
and I hate when I do it because I'm like
no I miss some dialogue like H it sucks
okay so we scan that uh the screen is
frozen hold on screen's Frozen damn it
uh okay hold on a sec Taye said this
might happen uh oh should I wait yeah
okay hold on hold on everybody you can
still hear
me uh okay let me go back
to I'm getting some might be
Tay no not
Tay okay we're back we got it sick sorry
about that we've been having some weird
issues it's been happening if that if
that happens again just let me know and
I can fix it although I don't think it
should happen again it's this a we're
using isn't the
atere
could
system ding our power one person says F
dialogue you would not like this game
then don't don't play it
wait oh hello oh that definitely doesn't
happen if you're a girl really I don't
think so what happen I don't remember
that
happening she doesn't tackle him oh like
my character like brought it up again
he's like oh like do you always tackle
you know like when I was flirting with
her I've been studying this tech for
months I don't know how you activated
those gphs but you have to let all right
we we'll Renegade push her off all right
time to get
off damn don't being sat on huh Chrono
krono krower again wants to know if you
need to know the full uh back story for
Mass Effect in order to enjoy this game
no it helps but no I mean it seems like
most most of the political issues that
characters are dealing with in Mass
Effect 1 2 and 3 they're kind of
separated from because they're in
Andromeda not the Milky Way yeah a lot
of a lot of the like but it seems like
some of the rivalries are still there
like between different races yeah like
San still kind of don't like Krogan
Krogan still don't like everyone uh yeah
some of that stuff's still there and
they do have uh they actually got this
really nice
uh actually never mind I can't talk
about that
uh oh it's it's not it's not much of a
spoiler but I'm like no wait actually
can't talk about that never mind uh but
there is a thing later in the game that
actually is a clever way of explaining
like some backstory stuff if you if you
want to that I thought was kind of
clever um I guess krono KRA who's asking
these questions trying to get his friend
to get it I would if you're trying to
get your friend to get it I would I mean
I'd wait to see what multiplayer looks
like because multiplayer from Mass
Effect 3 was pretty fun and oh the madok
yes I like this and the combat is really
good in this so I think the multiplayer
could be a good reason to get them on
board all right so this here's the uh
The Remnant which are these like robotic
uh ancient machines they kind of remind
me what are those what is it in Halo is
it the in Halo the 4Runner are they the
four runners well they're called the
Prometheans PR all right let's uh grab
this guy so I can and then I can launch
him yeah launch him yeah that's rad so
to do that uh you have to actually have
both the pull and the throw power so you
like pull them and then you throw them
after
not
um P strike says hope you like orange
and blue because you're getting it oh
like colors yeah do you like lens flare
yeah film grain they brought back the
film grain I did you turn it off it
looks like you turned yours off though
no mine's on maybe it's just not
noticeable should be on I you're right I
can't really see it though it's easier
to see in when it's darker as it should
be but uh yeah they took the film grain
out of three and I I remember I was like
one of those five people that's like
why' you take the film grain out
BioWare brought it back start a forum
yeah I started a forum only one started
two other people supporting you what is
it change.gov or whatever yeah
everyone's complaining about the ending
and you just want the film grain yeah I
just want the film grain that was me
that was my the hill I stood
Oni easy uh someone says it just froze
for looks like it's still up for us so
uh maybe refresh your page here take myv
points I'll be yeah it's still going for
usch make sure just be careful this
planet's all kinds of strange yeah it's
still going for us so I would recommend
trying to okay so uh now was PB there oh
man uh one of our mods says film grain
is the worst who said
that get out of
here film graen is the worst when you're
talking see I it doesn't look like yours
is on though I I swear it's on maybe I'm
I'm kind of blind so yeah film grain is
on okay take your word for it maybe it's
just not much on the May it's more on
the PC I don't know chromatic aberration
on though I haven't noticed any of that
oh I've noticed some of that a little
stylistic effect maybe I have it off on
mine
uh yeah oh let me I show some of the the
uh Quest stuff so we got priority Ops
which are the main missions you you have
allies and relationships which are
related to uh characters loyalty
missions are going to be in here that
kind of stuff uh Helia assignements are
sort of the the like major side quests
so you know like really heavy in like
dialogue and story stuff like that
additional tasks are where you get your
uh like hey go Scan 10 Wildlife you know
like go skin some minerals like more
more that kind of quest they're they're
not bad like I said there is some
dialogue related to them
but uh the game at least makes it very
easy where if you're not very interested
in those kinds of quests you can uh kind
of ignore them which is nice uh uh Inky
Doo which is cie know if uh or how the
voice acting is I like it I I like the
voice acting it's yeah I mean there's
some characters that like don't sound
great but I mean there's a lot of voice
like there there there has to be someone
who's not yeah you know you know what
I'm saying like totally I think it's on
par with previous fir War works as far
as the voice acting goes especially I
like uh I like uh Scott Ryder main uh M
male Rider who's voiced by noan North so
you know he's always going to turn into
good performance but I'm not sure who
voices her but the that's noan North
what Scott Rider yeah cuz I saw behind
the scenes it sounds like noan North but
sounds hell like Nolan North you tell me
that's not Nolan North oh I yeah I'm
pretty positive maybe the chat knows who
it
is when they s I am I was fooled then I
swar that was noan North it sounds a lot
like him but what I was going to say is
the little I've heard of female Rider I
really like her voice actor a lot I
think she like I I played a little bit
of the opening of female Rider and I I
think she kills it from what I've
heard yeah it's not noan North God I
swear it was noan North it sounds like
um I'm usually so spoton with voice
actors ah damn it take away my voice
actor
card cred I don't I can't find it
there's yeah I saw little doc like mini
doc bio where there it showed the two
characters I was convinced it was Nolan
North you goofed man ah I'm so
disappointed in
myself ready it it is an easy mistake to
make though it does sound a lot like
Nolan North it's like U I think the
other one I I always thought uh McCree
sounded like Troy Baker I yeah I did I
like I swore he was Troy Baker and
everyone's like no he's not Troy Baker
I'm like oh okay let's grab this see and
grab this guy from here
yeah let's throw
him oh look at that that's pretty cool
that is
good uh want know if we're going to
stream uh oh boy stream Persona 5 I hope
we stream uh do we can we stream it not
I don't I don't know I don't think yet
so you and me are are both big Persona
fans right or at least I'm I'm a huge I
like all of them I've only played four
four four is great so I'm very excited
for five we're both definitely going to
check it out I know Lucy has been
playing it over in the UK Lucy and tomor
are also huge and apparently tor's
already spent 100 hours in that game so
I heard it I hear I hear it's not very
good uh yeah they they apparently love
it they've been spending a ton of time
in it we haven't got a chance to play it
ourselves but I definitely want to play
it so at the very least I'm sure someone
will stream it um maybe maybe can can
they Tom tayloron that's the name um I
think they can stream but I don't do it
that often okay yeah we'll figure that
out so someone will stream the
game um got another question from cie
yeah uh she says hi guys big fan just
one more question how do you sleep at
night knowing you killed Garis your
let's play I don't sleep
ever uh for those that may not make
sense to a lot of people but uh Jean
Luke and I are actually doing a sort of
let's play called the status party on
the Citadel to lead up to the release of
Mass Effect Andromeda and actually it'll
continue after but we are basically
killing your favorite characters in Mass
Effect it's it's heartbreaking but it's
kind of entertaining because we're
basically playing Mass Effect in a way
probably most people
didn't uh can I get him can I get him oh
I missed
but yeah if you're just now tuning in we
are playing Mass Effect Andromeda this
isn't this is early the game comes out
in about a week now um but so we started
out in the Tempest and now we are just
kind of
exploring that was
[Applause]
rad wait is he still alive yep he got
up dang it uh by the way this use your
ability to send him flying again he
needs to go back into thisy I will uh
the reason I can see them is uh part of
my
profile ability lets me uh see
enemies
goodbye people are calling us
SST see
I that's pretty cool I haven't used this
yet it kind of like doesn't interest me
like the shield like I don't play that
way it it's like a super cool addition
cuz you see other characters in The
Other Mass Effect do it do like a biotic
Shield yeah and it's something that I
always like kind of wanted to use that
was actually like a tough fight I think
that would be sick in multiplayer right
having that I definitely think it makes
sense for a character who's uh very
shotgun heavy maybe a biotic charge CU
like you do the charge then you
immediately maybe Pull up The
Shield um there we go but yeah if you
guys have any questions make sure to uh
yeah yeah uh I'm going to get to another
big combat area I'm aware of we're going
to meet another character actually
nice work hey that guy's still alive
over there the one you threw yeah drive
your M run over
him a I missed him a dang
it there we
go oh target practice hit him oh someone
hit him ooh wow that's a lot of blood
whoever shot him probably probably
Vetra
okay uh someone to know do different
profile options open different dialogue
options I don't think so because you can
profile options yeah so like depending
on what profile you have does that
change your dialogue op not that I'm
aware profile seems specifically related
for combat so it's just for combat so
it's not so much like uh Mass Effect one
2 and 3 where if you like boost your
Renegade or Paragon or whatever or level
that up you get new uh dialogue options
it's not so much how it works but one
thing that your um profile does change
is kind of your movement style a little
bit I mean you still have like a a jump
jet you still have a dash I
should I'm okay I'm going to unlock some
really soon um I'm going to try and grab
the I want to show you the blink one if
I can get it because it's two points but
yeah like if you it was kind of like a
Mass Effect 3 multiplayer um if you were
a biotic then you'd use things like when
when you dash you wouldn't roll you do
like a biotic warp or something like
that um and it's similar to that
yeah I can make that happen I can get
some profiles unlocked um yeah
unfortunately we're still really early
on so the great I can't show off too
many of the profiles yet cuz I haven't
unlocked the great Gandalf says yo my
dudes what are the romance options
that's that's extremely important yo so
not aware fully but like I said I've
been able to flirt with everybody on the
ship uh as we saw earlier in the Stream
uh the uh engineered seems way into us
so that's cool uh I definitely know you
can flirt with PB um took off his head
Vetra I think I did take off that guy's
head uh I'm pretty sure you can flirt
with
Vetra uh I could flirt with cor and Liam
um don't know why I'd want to but I can
cor maybe but definitely not
Liam although Liam's trying to do a
thing where uh never mind can't say that
take it back I keep almost being like
well let me say this cool thing and I'm
like no can't talk about
that it just hit firing with a sniper
not the best TR tactic yeah but it looks
cool it does okay let's H we can
definitely throw some guys off oh this
guy he's got a he's like chain gun yeah
you got to take down the shield first
before
I am really low on
ammo I've not had an issue with usually
all right yeah drop them just drop
them see you that works
HTI oh any sign of Coran yet no they do
mention them though they they mention
that
[Music]
the so there there are the several arcs
that were supposed to get
to
uh get to Andromeda and you can ask like
hey uh are there ever going to be other
arcs and they were like well the next
planned Arc was going to be a Coran Arc
uh okay that was also supposed to have
yeah DLC or like if they're ever going
to do another one maybe that it's kind
of kind of seems like they're out it's
kind of a shame yeah yeah they they I I
would have liked to have seen more races
like that I imagine you there has to
have been one Coran on one of the many
arcs or on the Nexus or something the
Coran at least I understand from like
the way they function as a society you
know they're very like that's true that
kind of makes sense that it would be
sort of an All or Nothing kind of thing
yeah uh TJ Maxx is because BioWare hates
poran fire hat
Coran man I do not remember being this
hard one I was flying
earlier
UHS okay I grab him well he doesn't
realize that you turned off his shield
which is kind of annoying there we
go has Andromeda ever mentioned the
previous games not yet at least that
I've noticed but you do at the beginning
you do pick um what gender your Shepherd
was because I'm assuming yeah he or she
will get referenced
mhm um yeah so are there any are there
any weapons that have infinite ammo yes
uh yeah there are laser weapons yeah
those ones have a cool down rather than
ammo which I I like that they kind of
have taken the approach
of incorporating both Mass Effect one
and Mass Effect uh two and three Style
of like weapons yeah jeez I'm in a bad
spot here do you have the spear biotic
ability that was pretty cool I do uh the
Lance the Lance that's what it's called
yeah I have that
one someone wants to see the map maybe
after we clear this out we can take a
look at the map see what it looks like
what you doing up there
buddy HOH not good oh
boy oh
woo see Shield is
useful I don't know how long it'll hold
though long enough for me to get my
Shields
back this one's pretty long yeah I
wonder if it's just waiting until it no
no there's a little bar yep there it
goes
uh questions questions question is it on
switch nope on
switch
all right dead woo okay what difficulty
did you pick this should be normal okay
yeah cuz I played this exact section
last night on normal and I dude I I've
played this section Breeze through it I
played this section A couple times and I
had no issues I don't not know why I'm
having so much trouble right now with it
you haven't died yet so I haven't died
so kudos to me I guess but
man for whatever
reason
any other questions in the chat um well
actually gun
crew of two looks like it says actually
Corin are in the game BioWare did
confirm this and you may actually kill
them or save them based on your actions
what okay that's kind of a heavy spoiler
I didn't know that yeah I don't think
that's right though but I don't know
oh level four all right there we go now
we can let's do do you know if the
enemies scale cuz I was level two so
maybe that's why it was easy but this is
still the same level I was last time so
I don't I don't know that's a good
question uh yeah put points into
that yes unlock Vanguard unlock Explorer
Okay so
I get AR Joes know if the worlds feel
empty when you explore them
uh so far I haven't had that issue yet
um this is the only like re uh Planet
I've had a chance to
explore um heavily and it kind of makes
sense for the planet we'll see like
later planets uh how that how that holds
up um it hasn't really bothered me that
much though so far so let's see
Vanguard melee attx restore Shield s if
on the Vanguard uh profile and uh so
this is cool here so if I if I I now use
my biotics to warp around instead of my
jet that's pretty cool um yeah gun crew
wolf says there was an interview on
there on bior channel so yeah I guess
Coran are in this game oh okay so explor
this one's cooler though is you uh
warp so you can
actually War through stuff which I think
is really really fun this this is my can
you warp through that Shield right there
yep yeah that's cool yeah so this is my
my current favorite that's the range on
that is way further than the Boost too
can you warp through that wait no you
should try to warp through the hold on
no no fly over no I can't do that wait
like uh cuz there's that bubble over
there you know what I'm talking about oh
see if you can warp through that without
having turn it off I bet probably not
but I bet not cuz it's a story thing but
let's try it anyway let's try to break
the game
no try it again n doesn't let you good
try who it's kind doesn't like
that oh here we're going to get a
another story section Bone Crusher 360
with how many Power Rangers are are
there in this game uh n so far haven't
seen
any turn the sound up to
[Music]
this
I love the look of this guy yeah he
looks great of his little bone go
key um no there's no Co-Op campaign in
this unfortunately that was pretty
cool well yeah guess it
was still haven't told me who you are
oh come on Drax stop that Vetra what are
you doing
here I'm with the Pathfinder that
Pathfinder I friend of vet a friend of M
different yeah oh really I love that
Scott
Ryder so oh that's an interesting thing
I'm dra he says he said my name is Scott
rer you can pick your character's name
in The Character Creator you can you can
pick a totally random name Tre us I
decided whatever I'm terrible with names
I'll just go with the default name Scott
Rider he actually says his name a lot
though and it makes me so here's my
theory on this yeah
because the you cannot change the name
of the twin right checking out these
monoliths so I think they recorded lots
of VO with like the names too yeah that
makes sense I think so so I think they
were able to like sh I think that's I
think that's really cool though because
yeah I wish I I wish I stayed with Sarah
for mine but I changed yeah like I I
like that you have the ability to say
I'll just stick with the default name
and then they actually like integrate
that it's fting ground troops obviously
they couldn't do a thing where they like
what is it like in um Fallout 4 where
like your robot would like have like a
hundred different names that he would
respond to could use someone with but
they only got away with that because it
was only that one character who would do
that to in the chat wants know if we can
romance him I don't know besides the day
I help the I'd like to think so that's
the only one that hasn't given me the
option and also he's like a grandfa do
you want a romance like a really old
Krogan stronger why not particularly
interested in this alien
Tech
Remnant yeah
that I'm going to go find more to shoot
try to keep your head out
there
all right
okay I haven't been doing it that much
but uh I do have the scanner by the way
which you can scan stuff with yeah talk
about not that exciting to look at yeah
that's kind of why I've been not doing
it uh you want to do it though because
you do get you see there you have your
little points you get research points
and those are what you use to uh
research like new Blueprints and stuff
for uh what's in there new guns and
stuff
some alloy shotgun receiver keep jumping
up see how high you can get up here
there's like a little platform you can
jum let's try
and yeah get on top of there I don't
know why let's just do
it uh someone wants to know if there's
falling damage in this game I think
we're about to find out yeah let's find
out good question all right where where
are we dropping uh to the right like
kind of in between yeah yeah right
thread that needle
all right well the game doesn't like
that interesting so no falling Dam well
I guess we took damage huh I wonder what
they learned we did take some Shield
damage uh this is on Playstation there
is falling damage yes I'm playing on the
PlayStation 4 man I I like warping like
this
just that's yeah it's pretty cool it's
really
fun
I think this this one might have a
little
puzzle this must been what Mike was
doing he was like why am I playing
sidoku oh yeah yeah there's a sidoku
puzzle you get to
do see the other ones over here um
someone a lot of questions about the
performance on PS4 you kind of talked
about this already but do mind catching
people up to on so far it's been running
at 30 frames a second uh which has been
pretty solid haven't had any issues on
that front uh have had a couple weird
technical issues uh the game froze at
one point
for like 5 seconds and then kept going
the only time happen no hard crashes or
anything like that uh I did get stuck in
the geometry once I like warped into it
um or dashed into it I feel like that's
just
a partly my fault partly just like weird
geometry thing yeah
I've gotten stuck in geometry in what
I've played but I got out like I didn't
have to reset yeah I did have one really
bad uh example of the texture Popp in
for the most part it's not been it's
been fine but there was one example
where it was like really really bad uh
but that was it it was only that one
time uh got a couple questions here too
I don't know if we can talk about this
actually um okay you did good but I'll
see I'll let you decide how complex is
the management side of the game like
choosing which people to wake up from
Cry of sleep and such uh that that part
is after what we're supposed to what we
can talk about after this section so
unfortunately we cannot talk about that
okay um well then someone wants to know
if we've talked about R&D at all we
talked a little bit about it um but do
we want to oh like crafting that kind of
stuff just I guess how it works yeah uh
it's pretty standard so when you scan
you get these research points and one is
Andromeda initiative one is Milky Way
technology and one is Remnant technology
or not Andromeda initiative one's
Andromeda yeah one is like Andromeda
points one is Remnant points and one is
uh Milky Way points and so you use those
to buy blueprints for
stuff and then uh you can then make
those those things you know whether
they're weapons or armor uh using um
materials you find uh you can find them
throughout the world you can also uh buy
them from vendors
um my only real so it's pretty standard
as far as how it works it it's pretty
straightforward my only real issue with
it is that there hasn't been a way
to if I if I really need to find a very
specific material there's no good way to
like track it or anything like that
which has kind of been a little bit of
an issue as far as like wanting to get
stuff for a very specific upgrade I sort
the way I sort of been using it is I'll
just go out you know get my materials
playing the game and then when I'm back
on the Tempest I'll just like stop in
and be like all right what can I make
and that's kind of how I've been playing
it so
far
okay um let's see
here they want to know about the biotic
build too oh biotic build what do you
want to know about
biotics I don't know someone just wants
us to talk about what we think of the
biotic build I like I like the biotic
abilities a lot they're really fun yeah
they're they're usually they tend to be
the ones I lean to um there's some
really cool ones like John Luke's
actually been doing the the throw a lot
right grab on them for a while and then
just launch them yeah we can buy some
new skills as well yeah is there
anything you guys want to see do you
want to see what are the options biotic
Tech yeah the tech skills are actually
fun um I know I think biotic is kind of
like the go-to like Space Magic but I
like the tech stuff too it's it is the
flamethrower is really satisfying to use
for sure I could like assign that to um
jeez lots of questions do teammates gain
experience uh when not in the party uh
yes okay cool it seems like Universal
thing you can put points into them um
not as in- depth obviously not as in
depth it the squad uh interaction in
combat seems pretty minimal there's not
really much you can do with them
unfortunately which I does feel like a
little bit of a step back unfortunately
um pumpkin want to know if we've seen
anything similar to boss fights in this
game yet fights with different mechanics
or setups there is a uh cool fight with
like a giant Beast that I can actually I
think I can actually show that um I
should be able to get to that REM B uh
we'll do it after this
hostile he says like they don't seem
hostile and then they like immediately
start shooting at
you come on there we
go burn whoa hi there cor just fell out
of the
sky and warp went off
there we go
[Music]
okay oh yeah oh they want to see Nova
did you already use your no I can I can
buy a
Nova yeah I can get a point
Nova Singularity is one oh there's a lot
I don't think we have enough to do all
of them maybe Nova unfortunately cannot
activate Singularity oh cuz
we need at least n points n points in
biotics I did not pick biotic as a
starting ability so I unfortunately
cannot show off Singularity is there
anything
else uh I'll save that one point so if
anyone wants
to uh let's see here though these guys I
don't know how well these guys will be
for
it says Halo is more better Halo is more
better well put yep there oh wow that
was wow that was cool why are you blue
though good
question I am blue that was weird is
that supposed to happen I have no idea
it's my first time using that ability
also about to
die oh boy well dead there I'm
dead that's my problem with abilities
like Nova is you have to like really get
in there and it's like oh
no uh do you have to be a generic white
guy/girl nope uh full character
customization change your uh face and
your dad is in this game and their face
actually changes depending on how you
spect your character's yeah you can you
can customize both too so even if you
choose to play as male Rider you can
still customize your
twin here let's try and get that Nova
back let's try and like use it
properly yeah Nova is cool in the other
games but if you like Nova around a lot
of enemies you're screwed because it
just drains your sh because it drains
your Shields right I wonder if it does
that
here no it doesn't look like it nope
looked cool it did look cool especially
like oh man Nova's even cooler now that
you can like jetpack in the air and then
drop down on yeah exactly I like that
stuff a
lot no scope no scope
sniping
nice
all right so I think my guess is why you
turned blue is because I bet you smashed
into one of those blue like cry looking
tanks and I think you're probably yeah
froze let's try it TR kidding yeah yeah
smashing yeah that's I bet you that is
what that
was I can over that guy continue you
kind of looks like a metal gear it does
look like a metal gear
yeah all right no V to one of those
things just do it okay just do it no
those aren't the blue ones though you
got they are oh yeah they are I'm just I
have to wait okay wait till your health
is up waiting for it to recharge
and oh those are electricity well oh
wait a minute they're changing color do
you think you have to do that's what I
was saying I knew I knew I saw no no no
but what I'm saying is that when they
change color do you think it is a
different that's kind of Co maybe I
don't know cuz they were blue this one
doesn't seem to be
changing all right I think we're we're
done
yeah oh yes here's the uh sidoku puzzle
soku so we got to find some missing
stuff before we can do this rest
of wonder if i' get anything on the scan
uh by the way you can totally Respec at
any point um does it is there are you
punished for it I mean like is there so
when I tried to do it I don't know if it
costs more the higher level you are it
it costed me 20 credits oh it's nothing
yeah which is like nothing I was like oh
okay and you can just do it on on the
Tempest um where's that other okay so
there's one up there and then right you
have to like find
these
someone wants to know how smooth the
transition of
ability ability builds using the d-pad I
don't know what that means oh yeah yeah
yeah so here uh I might not have them
equipped here so you have favorites here
oh so at any point I did not know that
yeah it's pretty cool so uh I could say
all right now I want to
go say I want to go like
more right now I'm I'm kind of like mid
so you can make four different um
basically loadouts you can switch on the
Fly exactly that's cool uh so say I want
to make like a pure biotic one that's
like yeah like my backlash one so I'll
put that
here and put my uh pole here and then I
want to set it to the Vanguard
profile and then I'll sa favorites and
I'll put it there so then yeah you just
hit this button go to favorites and then
you just switch between the two and
you're done it's pretty it's pretty
straightforward uh looks like his name
is
Google uh he wants to know so do any of
your choices from the previous games
make it into this game no uh no not as
far as there there was no ability to
import or anything like that um it's so
far removed that actually I need to get
that other one first it would wouldn't
really make any sense
yeah I'll need to use the interface that
controls this uh can anyone knows the
difference between 30 and 60 frames a
second uh well as far as this game goes
so I started it on PS4 and I definitely
had like I thought it was fine like I I
didn't feel wanting at all um I didn't
feel but certainly like once I saw Aaron
play it at 60 frames on the PC I was
like oh wow that looks way nicer uh for
sure but this is the kind of game that
it doesn't feel like you're hampered by
being at 30
frames um I guess our Facebook stream
just died I have no control on that um I
know Facebook you can't stream for I
think longer than like a certain amount
of times that may be wide ended oops I
hit hit the wrong button and they summon
some
dudes go cor do your
thing oh that was cool uh we have mods
for our
gear uh mods yes there are mods you can
uh Equip to your
gear okay let's try this
again
so let's see yeah this just like a
sodoku
puzzle
cool cool
so they all have to be different this is
like
s is exactly what it is yep thank God
it's not an actual like full sidoku
puzzle though yeah uh with how many
squares normally there's nine right nine
yes yeah no
thanks okay and that should be it yep
there we go interf
successful there we go that's all three
of them right yep uh any mini games uh
apart from that sodoku puzzle not any
that I've noticed so far I haven't seen
any uh do you get full armor set so you
just upgrade your current armor so you
get uh bits and
pieces um there are like legs uh arms
which are like shoulders uh helmets and
then uh the uh chest plate and it seems
like there is some level of mix and
matching at at the very least you can um
wear like a different helmet it it
definitely looks weird though doing it
yeah I'm one of those people that would
want everything to be uniform now I'm
the same way they're right next to a
barrel you should NOA it no don't Nova
it but you should pop
it oh I think you took out I think I
took out someone she's been dying a lot
lately not pulling her
weight grab that
guy
nope
oh out ammo but yeah so if you guys are
excited for Mass Effect curious about it
tomorrow we will be doing another stream
and we're going to play
multiplayer we're going to hope to play
multiplayer hopefully there'll be enough
people playing to play multiplayer yeah
that's the only worry uh um so make sure
to uh come by tomorrow to check that out
I'm not sure what time it is at do you
know 1:00 1:00 so same time as it was
today um 1:00
Pacific it's possible we might push to
like 1:30 just to check and make sure
that people are playing cuz 1:00 is when
they're supposed to start playing so
okay uh Spartan 1047 once to know can
you change the color of your armor uh
you can change your uh your like civvy
uniform you can change your civvy
uniform I'm not sure if you can paint
job your armor I haven't seen anything
about that you can change the paint job
of the Nomad which is cool that is
pretty cool there's a lot of nomad
customization isn't there yes all right
slow turn this down a little bit uh yeah
there's some decent amount of
customization on The Nomad there we go
there's myo um and we've had some
question about multiplayer they want to
if it's a versus match or if there's PVP
no so it is PVE meaning you're going to
fight off waves with four other Squad
mes very similar to Mass Effect four
four jeez Mass Effect
three yeah oh he clipped it I think that
broke his back I think he's dead
yes I wish you could like use biotic
pull like pull cor around I don't know
why grab her or like Liam just like
carry him around uh goo wants to know
how difficult is the game uh I've I
found it pretty fine so far I was having
a struggle earlier for some reason yeah
this is normal um but there are what
five difficulties I think I saw yep all
it goes all the way up to Insanity they
also brought back that narrative uh
difficulty from uh yeah so it's
narrative casual or easy than normal so
if you're the kind of person who's like
and just wants the story but doesn't
really care for the combat uh you are
covered I get the feeling this game
would be pretty tough on insane yeah I
imagine it would be there we go that's
like the Zelda hard mode is like
supposed to come out and I'm like that
game is hard enough as is I don't need
to do that yeah like I don't need
that I was just thinking the same
thing okay we where uh someone want to
know if you have EA access are you're
able to stream before full release I'm
I'm pretty sure you can yeah I I don't
imagine they would be able to stop you
if like if you get it early like no yeah
you're you're definitely allowed to
stream you only have 10 hours to play it
though so I me yeah you'll have access
to 10 hours so don't leave your like
don't like leave it on overnight
otherwise that's that's your time that's
a good point yeah don't go don't go to
the bathroom don't eat yeah every time
you need a break just quit out of the
game okay so that right there is the
main objective however we cannot show
that okay so we're going to do you said
there might be a boss we'd be able to
show yeah there's like a kind of mini
boss yeah let's do over
here uh maybe I think it's do a little
bit of exploring check that out and
probably wrap up around that
yeah so yeah so uh there's a lot of the
map you've noticed that like isn't
discovered right now and right now when
I try to expl for it it activates like a
level three radiation which uh will like
kill me even when I'm in The Nomad so
the game seems to be kind of gating off
a lot of the map for the
moment and uh is kind of set up in a way
where you will come back to the planet
later uh which is kind of cool that they
don't sort of force you to like explore
to death One Planet all the way at once
but kind of have you keep kind of
bouncing back and forth between
them okay I like that yeah I like that
you're not just cuz actually we talked
about before the stream how in like uh
you were saying an inquisition you kind
of like you want to stay in that first
AA for a long time and it gets really
old yeah like the the
game yeah totally we're like the game
doesn't really like tell you to leave
but so you kind of like instinctively
like I'm going to stay here and like
fill everything out but then you really
shouldn't the game actually kind of
forces you to leave in a in a good way
um okay we got another one are there any
achievements for playing the game on
insane
or
trophies don't know if we should open up
the trophy list because there might be
spoilers yeah I won't open it up I
haven't I'm if it's like the other Mass
Effect games if you want if you want you
could go to our full screen I could
quickly check if uh we want to check for
the person
um we could do that I don't know are
people curious about that yeah um I mean
I imagine there probably is though yeah
if it's anything the other ones there is
but if people are that curious we we
could we could check Okay so
way too
quiet I feel bad I'm like skipping
through all the dialogue trying to
stream games like this is so hard yeah
cuz you really wanted
like soak in that
atmosphere but really we're here to to
show off the game
to you
guys oh is this the mini boss thing yeah
there little mini bosses I called the
[Music]
FI no go it does sound like
L see I'm not crazy for thinking that
son
of get up
here all right we got some cat coming
in yeah that guy okay I fought I I
fought the them at the demo yeah those
things are of course I think you're
going to take down no problem you should
get eaten by it first though really yeah
you should get eaten by o is it cool it
looks pretty cool all right I can get
eaten by it see if it'll actually like
do it
though yeah oh oh oh
No and then it punches you out that was
instant
death wow told you should get eaten by
it it's rad that was
cool I like how he doesn't swallow you
he just takes a huge V you throws you on
the ground and then just socks you in
this stuff I think he he wasn't happy
with how he tasted Pro I mean there's a
lot of metal bits right like get that
armor I would want
that uh where's Commander Shephard he is
in the Milky Way galaxy fighting Reapers
while we're in Andromeda screwing around
getting eaten by oh no put me all the
way back over here all right I guess I
shouldn't have told you to do that it's
kind of worth it though yeah no big
deal I can get back there pretty quick
that's okay it's not like we're driving
the moo yeah we're driving a cool
vehicle with a boost and it can fly and
it's got a little bit of a
jump
yeah someone said harambe is back and
he's pissed off I think I think those
things are going to have to be called
space harambes from space harambes
oh
boy yeah this game looks nice good
environment the the environments the
scenery look really good it's just the
the the details the little face it's
really the it's really the characters
for me I think that's the hiccup like
The Nomad looks great you know armor
looks really solid like the art
direction is just as fantastic as it's
always
been you unless here it says have
viability so if I pull up the map
there's like a viability percentage for
like how viable the planet is to be
colonized so like the more stuff you do
the more it like increases viability um
I'm curious if like cuz it seems like
you can like create outposts as you make
it more viable you find locations but I
wonder how in depth it gets like I
wonder if like if you hit 100% or
whatever you can have like a little kind
of City obviously not like a hug City
but
um yeah I wonder that too like with
people and quests and stuff like
that people are really loving that soku
thing they're really into theace talking
about space soku still all right it's
good cuz it yeah
yeah
um okay let's turn on this
terminal can customize the h
not that I'm aware of
no if you can do it on PC it's a good
question might be a mod probably well
not yet but I'm sure at some
point you should get eaten by it no I'm
falling for that one
again oh that guy that guy's a real
problem yeah i' been more worried about
him than space harambe right now
let's get you and you're
gone man that throw is pretty good
Splash right in the water that's so
cool he he's swimming is he swimming
he's done
okay do you have a
sniper dang it I was he came out cuz the
your cursor turned red so I think he
drowned
man
oh hi there can you swim in this game we
should take a dip in that Lake too if we
can after we figure this
out I wonder if you can upgrade that to
deflect I think you can that's
rad reminds me of
art that was cool yeah that's my little
melee uh ground
pound
Oh shoot no oh is it back it puts me
back over I hope it doesn't use the
false rer as someone says in
chat I should have saved I should have
made a
save oh please
don't uh yeah in the free roam area
played in the in the in the in the
preview event there were those things
just wandering around okay
closer really just like wandering around
those things just wander around those
fiends there a lot of them but like yeah
I'd like shoot one and run to an enemy
Outpost and just wait and like they'd
like and they' just battle it out and
then I'd clean up the
scraps all right I was try and get this
guy
s oh is the one we get right but it
didn't have
time looks like a war
zone all right
safe
okay over
Works don't
care how many bil can you have mapped at
once you can have three at a time three
at a time but you've got four different
loadouts you can swap between so I can
say ah one mess with this one
now although actually no I want this one
actually what are the main bugs in the
PC version so youve been playing PC I've
been playing a little bit of PC I've had
frame rate issues geometry issues like
some weird pop in um like so far nothing
gamebreaking like I haven't had to
haven't any crash I Haven had to restart
it although on my PC at work I can't run
it at all which is kind of an issue dude
here's the thing though I wouldn't I
wouldn't judge that one against the game
that PC's been having issues yeah that
PC has been having issues but mine back
home uh seems to run fine I'm on a
972 as well so it's not like I can't
like run it it as good as I want but it
seems to hit 60 during like I don't know
a lot of oh God oh God oh God okay we're
good no we're good we're good we're good
it's fine uh have you found any good
combos with the abilities you can chain
together so yeah so right here if you
pull uh you can then throw you have to
combine them both together so that's a
pretty good one uh I'm definitely
curious if you can do more combinations
that would be like a little fun yeah uh
like test I I'm sure you can I imagine
you
can lack of sidoku would be game
breaking can I grab him whoa oh boy oh
shoot what happened the FI was right
next to me oh how did he get up here I
don't know probably jumped space harambe
he's not
happy I was like I'll grab this guy and
everything oh
man jeez oh boy you are hurt yeah
oh man the movement is pretty nice in
this game FR R is actually kind of
chugging a little bit here which yeah
the frame rate did just taking some nose
ties which I I hadn't had those issues
previously so I'm not sure what's
causing
it by the way there is a huge day one
patch happening for this game that we do
not have so um let's hope that a lot of
the issues that we've been experiencing
are hopefully going to go away I mean
obviously you know we'll make sure to do
our due diligence and and test that
stuff out but yeah like there's right
now it's it's a
little we can still kind of say it's
it's disheartening to see it but uh I
don't want to like speak for how much of
it will still be there yeah yeah that is
a good
point uh all right so we got another
good question here uh got to know are we
able to get drunk and wake up on the
bathroom floor just like Shephard in
Mass Effect one there is a bar there is
a bar in this game and you can drink it
confirmed Bo drink the bar jeez you can
drink the bar uh you can drink at the
bar uh that makes more sense I was able
to I didn't drink a couple I should I
should have drank a couple times to see
if you get like that swimmy effect I
didn't I didn't check that but you can
there is a bar and you can drink
there
cool all right I'm I'm so sorry I keep
like failing this
thing uh I'm going to
move get
flamethrower cry
beam
this is a cool
ability barricade and then I'm going
to
Explorer let's
see let's put the
flamethrower and let's put the Lance the
Lance is like a really good just damage
dealing bi IC all right
cool override
it temp we have unnown I've noticed
those orange crates are still around
from Mass Effect two and three yeah see
them all over the place yeah there's a
lot of break two and three but you can't
break them in this it's kind of weird
it's like don't let it grab
you should let it grab you
no oh I think I equipped the wrong one
sec
I equip the Tactical cloak not the
flamethrower although the Tactical cloak
is
cool just get rid of that thing let's
take it out first getting getting pretty
close to it though no no no
haha run
warp
yeah reinfor
out is that the Lance that you're
throwing yeah cor is
down I don't have time for that sharp
that thing is out there and the
everything's grounded till they're gone
oh hey cor still
talking she's died a lot I guess been
knocked
down yeah see that does a decent amount
of
damage oh my
gosh yeah get out of
there do you have Omni gel Med gel I
think
so is that even a thing in this no I
have Shield capacitors I should put
those
on
I don't think Omni gel is a thing in
this game I at least I haven't seen it
yet yeah there we go oh
no space
harambe Nothing Gets By him how long
have we been going for uh we going for
hour and 40 minutes all right well at
this point one more shot one more shot
to redeem yourself if you don't do
it we'll have to actually I'll be
playing tomorrow so maybe you should
level up Cor so she stops dying that's a
good point I don't think I actually have
her leveled
up yeah let's just auto level yeah we'll
just Auto yeah yeah there we go that
might help that might help a little bit
yeah uh let's get the Lance back on I
wish there were more places you could
swap weapons out at
like it seems like you can only do it in
those forward operating bases and
forward operating bases Tempest yeah
like just like I wish like buildings and
stuff like that there were like weapons
lockers and stuff like that honestly
that would have been nice they should
have just done the Mass Effect one thing
where you can just kind of have them
whenever you know just no real like you
can just sort of do that anytime you
want
flamethrower maybe I'll go the Tactical
cloak that might be
useful and if I'm doing that um switch
profile to I don't know if you knew this
but Shepherd is actually called John
sidoku Shephard by joh soku shephard I
remember that clear as day John sidoku
shepher the sidoku is still going strong
people people are loving the S love the
soku does it can you swim we want to
figure that out actually I don't know if
we'll be able to do it in this stream
though but we threw well that's how
we'll end we'll trym yeah we have an
unknown enemy EV the
Pathfinder on go wait what female Tyrion
that's like a unicorn yeah you don't see
many female tan female tan female
krogen female salarians which look
exactly like nor slightly different yep
that was always so weird about Mass
Effect how like some had different
genders and others didn't like the only
one they kind of explained it was uh
aari cuz they're like they all have
different genders just for whatever
reason they never bothered to like
that's what I mean like you just never
saw
him all right I'm just going to like PE
shoot this guy like
a I have no more patience for you yeah
you just got to take out
harambe I don't know calling him harambe
and now you're shooting at him is bring
him back oh bad memory point
point oh here's
a who's shooting at me over
there the heck is that um cage
wander says he'd laugh his butt off if
he found out if we find out that the
Turon is gas's
sister can't see that happening but no
he has a sister I don't do no I think
you find our name though I don't think
it's that'd be that'd be really
interesting
but I still think I mean I think she
already has a name I just don't know
cor's last name is
Harper yes which and if depending on how
much of uh The elusive man you know
about that is the elusive Man's last
name so yes no idea if that's actually
connected or not but that's interesting
I have a feeling we'll hear something
about it cuz why would they that seems
too obvious to not that name if she's
not but unless it was like a total
mistake
yeah there go she's she's still dying
not it's not cor this time
okay there we go oh it's frozen again
it's frozen again a man uh hold on sorry
about this don't worry guys I'm just
trying not to
die
all right I'm flaming I'm going to
describe I'm setting a guy on fire yep
he's on fire okay I've gone invisible
now give it a couple
seconds should come back up any second
now and yeah so just FYI this isn't the
game this is our setup is having issues
yeah this has nothing to do with the
game yeah Jean Luke is still playing um
but it's back up now should be
good apologies for that we're going to
try to get this sorted out before
tomorrow this is an a we are using but
it's we've we've been having issues with
this a
a bet down again yeah and cor too come
on come on come on come on come on
yep and
up yeah toast him toast him there we
go
what's up Cor man squads dying left and
right I know oh I don't think I upgraded
them
again no I did no I totally did upgrade
them that was that was this run they're
all bluring
together so do we just have the fiend
left maybe I actually haven't seen him
in a bit yeah he might have got taken
down by my squad huh sure they're just
too busy Dy what are you
do I'm am I playing on a hard difficulty
cuz it was I was not having this much
trouble when I was playing earlier did I
accidentally burned you should
check yeah I'm really worried though
it's going to be totally normal and I'm
going to be just like
embarrassed just at my poor skills oh
hey there whoa he's not done yet
yet he is definitely not done almost
there now he's well
done good one focus on the good one
woo it oh no the music's still playing
yeah the music's still playing we also
need to take a dip in the lake we
do come
on oh
no I mean am I good oh right there no
that's uh no no no no look look look
back that way see red on your radar
right there
oh guys we're just we're just just
chilling cool now I think we're done
nope
that wow that one
guy persistent this is they just don't
stop let's
uh we're going to throw this
guy she like kick him I don't know like
she biotic kicked him oh yeah that's
another thing you can do in combat here
is uh when you jump jet if you hold down
uh trigger yeah I use that a lot you can
like hover um come on come on I think
we're about going to end this stream in
next couple minutes but if you guys have
any last minute questions mine
nice if you guys have any last minute
questions before we end try to get them
off
now um have the games Rel released earli
for reviews yes this is a review copy
mhm but again without day one patch
without the day one patch yeah um and
we're going to test out see if we can
swim why does everyone keep talking
about sodoku because there's a space
sodoku miname in this all right do we
want to get up
here
uh we don't seem to be getting any
questions but all right let's jump in
the lake here let see what happens uh
good wants to know how linear is the
game uh so far it has been
uh I'd say like decently it kind of
reminds me a lot of Mass Effect one um
where
uh there there's right now at least in
this part of the game the missions are
pretty straightforward but uh there's a
good amount of like side quests like
walking around like um I I'd say it's
it's on par with previous mass games as
far as linearity
goes uh all right let's do
it nope can't swim can't swim
uh when are we going to stream
multiplayer that's probably a good good
good question to end on so if you
enjoyed this we are going to be
streaming multiplayer tomorrow at
probably 1 maybe 1:30 around that time
uh Pacific we want to make sure we can
get into multiplayer games and whatnot
but make sure to tune back for that and
then for more Mass Effect stuff make
sure to hit that subscribe button uh
because there's lots of Mass Effect
stuff on the
way last minute question uh last
question Dusty wants to know uh how deep
is the skill SK tree uh fun
experimenting with different character
bills uh yeah I like the skill tree A
lot's show it pretty good amount of um
you can kind of like mess with each of
them and within each of them there's
like multiple paths you can reset uh
your character to Respec uh it only cost
me 20 credits to do so at least at the
point in the game I was at uh so it
seems like there's a lot of chance just
like if you just want to mess around
with different powers you can uh totally
do that so yeah cool well thank you guys
for watching and like I said make sure
to subscribe and check out our Channel
because we've got plenty of more Mass
Effect stuff on the way and stuff that's
already there uh with that said see you
guys tomorrow I should
go